The answer is better + flight + search.
Let's do that together, and we'll talk about what happened.
Okay, I click submit, and I get taken to Google search results
for the phrase "better flight search."
I can see in the URL better + flight + search.
What are these pluses doing there?
Because you didn't type them in the search form.
The answer is because URLs can't have spaces in them,
your browser did what's called URL encoding or form encoding or URL escaping.
They're all basically words you'll see that refer to the same concept,
which is we turn spaces to pluses.
We also do some other things.
If we go back and enter some different text in here,
we can see even more behaviors.
Let me add an exclamation mark and hit submit.
Now you can see in the URL we have this %21.
That's because exclamation marks generally also get escaped.
Now, the behavior could be different in your browser.
All browsers have slightly different behaviors in this regard,
but this is what we see in ours, and you'll probably see something similar.